Y
PRO COMMUNITY AND ESPECIALLY
FROM AMERICA.
THIS WEEK AS PARENTS ACROSS
THE COUNTRY PROTEST
SCIENTIFICALLY A MASK MANDATES
FOR KIDS BIDEN TAPS THE
EDUCATION SECRETARY TO
THREATEN CLOSE ON THE SCHOOL
CLOSURES IN RESPONSE EVEN
BIDEN WEIGHED IN AGAINST
PARENTS AND CLOSURES AND
SCIENCE.
THE TEACHERS USING IS DOING
THE PARENT FOR THE CRIME TO
FIND OUT EXACTLY WHAT KIND OF
WOKE POISON THE SCHOOLS ARE
STEALING INTO THE MIND OF HER
CHILDREN WHILE THE UNIONS ONCE
AGAIN HOLD AMERICA'S CHILDREN
HOSTAGE WITH THREATENS TO
CLOSE SCHOOLS UNLESS THE
PREPOSTEROUS PANDEMIC DEMANDS
ARE MET.
WHAT IS THE SHOW?
THAT THE PEOPLE WHO SHOULD
HAVE THE POWER WHEN IT COMES
TO EDUCATION, PARENTS HAVE HAD
IT TAKEN AWAY BY AN UNHOLY
ALLIANCE OF THE EDUCATION
BUREAUCRACY.
FROM THE START OF THIS
PANDEMIC THE TEACHERS UNIONS
NEW THE AFFECTED CHILDREN THAT
EXPLOITED THAT FOR THEIR OWN
PERSONAL BENEFIT CLOSING
SCHOOLS IN AMERICA ALL
COUNTRIES AROUND THE WORLD
OPEN THERE'S UP OR BAND
CLOSING AT ALL POLITICAL
DEMANDS LIKE WEALTH TAXES
MEDICARE FOR ALL.
THE EVIL PUSH FOR BRAINWASHING
DANGEROUS RACE BAITING AND
THEN HEADLINING THE CONFERENCE
THE LEADERS OF THE TWO BIGGEST
TEACHERS UNIONS PROBABLY
DEFENDING RACISM IN THE
WORKING INDOCTRINATION THAT
TEACHERS UNIONS ARE THE
BIGGEST OPPORTUNITY CRUSHERS
IN AMERICA SACRIFICING
EDUCATIONAL STANDARDS AND
ACHIEVEMENT FOR POLITICAL
DOGMA THAT DUMBS EVERYTHING
DOWN WHILE DEMANDING MORE
MONEY, LESS WORK AND LAVISH
PENSIONS.
IN CALIFORNIA, 5000-DOLLAR
BONUSES, 7 PERCENT SALARY BUT
THAT A RETROACTIVE PAY RAISE
JUST TO SHOW WHAT.
THE TEACHERS UNIONS AMERICA
PUBLIC ENEMY NUMBER ONE
WINNING LIKE THIS?
CORRUPTION IS A BIG PART OF
IT.
FOR YEARS THE UNIONS HAVE
BRIBED NEW YORK STATE UNITED
OVER $13 MILLION TO DEMOCRATS
IN CALIFORNIA OVER 14 MILLION
AT THE NATIONAL LEVEL
$60 MILLION TO DEMOCRATS AND
WHAT DOES AMERICA GOT IN
EXCHANGE EVEN A LIBERAL
COLUMNIST POINTS OUT GREEKS
HAVE HIGHER HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATION RATES 15 EUROS IN
RUSSIA POLAND LATVIA AND OTHER
COUNTRIES ARE BETTER AT MATH
THAN AMERICAN COUNTERPARTS ONE
FIFTH OF AMERICA'S 15
-YEAR-OLDS CAN'T READ AT THE
LEVEL EXPECTED OF A TEN
-YEAR-OLD.
THE PERFORMANCE OF THE UNION
FOR THE PUBLIC SCHOOL SYSTEM
IS A COMPLETE CATASTROPHE.
OF COURSE HARDEST HIT ARE THE
COMMUNITIES THAT THE TEACHERS
UNIONS CLAIM THEY CARE ABOUT
NATIVE AMERICAN THIRD-GRADERS
PERFORMED 14 PERCENT LOWER
THIS YEAR COMPARED TO 2019
BLACK STUDENTS 15
POINTS, LATINO STUDENTS 17
POINTS LOWER IN MAJORITY BLACK
BALTIMORE CLOSE TO HALF OF THE
KIDS HAVE A GPA BELOW ONE.ZERO
IN CALIFORNIA IT IS THE
EQUIVALENT OF A FOUR-YEAR
ACHIEVEMENT GAP BETWEEN BLACK
AND MY EIGHTH GRADE STUDENTS
THE BATTLE OF THE TEACHERS
UNIONS THEY ARE NOT THE ONLY
REASON FOR THE MONUMENTAL AND
HUMILIATING FAILURE TO
PROPERLY EDUCATE OUR CHILDREN.
IN EVERY STATE AND LOCAL AREA
PUBLIC SCHOOL BUREAUCRACIES
WHO ARE IN CHARGE OF THE
SYSTEM PRESIDING OVER A
NATIONAL DISASTER.
IN BALTIMORE THEY HAVE
ACHIEVEMENT AND ACCOUNTABILITY
OFFERS AND IN BALTIMORE WHERE
KIDS ARE IN THE PUBLIC SCHOOL
SYSTEM FOR DECADES AND NEARLY
HALF BARELY GET ANY EDUCATION
AT ALL THAT EVERY SINGLE
BUREAUCRAT AT THE ACHIEVEMENT
ACCOUNTABILITY OFFICE GETS
$100,000 PER YEAR.
WHEN THE DEMOCRATS BLAME
REPUBLICANS AND RACISM AND
ANYONE BUT THEMSELVES FOR THE
POVERTY, INEQUALITY AND RACIAL
INJUSTICE THAT IS TOO COMMON
IN THE EXACT PLACES THEY RUN
, WE SAY NO.
IS NOT RACISM OR REPUBLICANS.
IT IS YOU USELESS INCOMPETENT
IDEOLOGICAL UNACCOUNTABLE
EDUCATION BUREAUCRAT PAY
YOURSELVES A FORTUNE FOR
PUBLIC MANY YOU ARE THE ONES
DESTROYING THE LIVES OF THE
LEASE ADVANTAGE KIDS IN
AMERICA.
IN CALIFORNIA SUPERINTENDENT
PAID NEARLY HALF A MILLION
DOLLARS FOR LESS THAN HALF THE
KIDS TO BE PROFICIENT IN MATH
AND IN RED STATES AS WE SHOWED
YOU LAST WEEK WITH THE FATCATS
REPORT LOCAL BUREAUCRATS WITH
MASSIVE SALARIES TOTALLY
UNRELATED TO PERFORMANCE ON
AND ON IT GOES BLOATED
BUREAUCRACY TAKING ON MANY AND
FAILING CHILDREN THE ENTIRE
EDUCATIONAL ESTABLISHMENT HAS
FAILED COLLEGES WHERE THEY
INCUBATE APPALLING TEACHING
PERIOD LIKE A VIRUS SENT TO
INFECT GENERATION AFTER
GENERATION OF CHILDREN THIS IS
A SYSTEMIC RACISM KAMALA
HARRIS THIS IS THE STRUCTURAL
CHANGE WE NEED ELIZABETH
WARREN.
WE HAVE STOOD BY WATCHING THE
PUBLIC SCHOOL SYSTEM CRUMBLE
ENDLESS TOP-DOWN REFORM FROM
NO CHILD LEFT BEHIND TO THE
RACE TO THE TOP OF THE SYSTEM
THAT IS BROKEN A POINT REFORM
A ROTTEN BUILDING YOU TEAR IT
DOWN AND BUILD A NEW ONE.
SOME SAY CHARTER SCHOOLS ARE
THE ANSWER.
YES SINCE THE FIRST ONE
ESTABLISHED IN 1992 THEY HAVE
PROVE THEIR WORTH.
THEY GAIN BETWEEN 35 AND 40
EXTRA DAYS OF LEARNING AND SEE
SEATTLE AND SIXTY-DAY STUDENTS
FROM L.A. CHARTER SCHOOLS ARE
MUCH MORE LIKELY TO BE
ELIGIBLE FOR STATE
UNIVERSITIES THEN UNION RUN
SCHOOLS.
GREAT LADDERS OF OPPORTUNITY
FOR BLACK AND LATINO AND
NEWARK AND NEW JERSEY AND IN
NEW YORK CITY EVEN WHEN THE
CHARTER SCHOOL CLASSES ARE IN
THE SAME BUILDING AS PUBLIC
SCHOOLS THEY DID BETTER.
THEY WORK BECAUSE THEY ARE
INDEPENDENT OF THE EDUCATION
BUREAUCRACY AND FREE FROM THE
LOW EXPECTATION, LOW
ACHIEVEMENT LOWEST COMMON
DENOMINATOR MADNESS ON THE
PUBLIC SCHOOL SYSTEM AND MOST
TEACHERS ARE NOT UNIONIZED SO
OF COURSE DEMOCRATS IN THE
TEACHER UNION PAYMASTERS HATE
THEM THE OTHER WEEK PELOSI WAS
VOTING TO CUT 40 MILLION FROM
THE CHARTER SCHOOL PROGRAM
DEMOCRAT POLITICIANS BLOCKING
CHARTER SCHOOL EXPANSION EVEN
WHEN DEMOCRATIC RESIDENTS
SUPPORTED CALIFORNIA GOVERNOR
NEWSOM ALSO SUPPORTED CHARTER
SCHOOLS ONCE THEN HE DECIDED
HE HAD TO SUCK UP TO THE
TEACHERS UNIONS TO GET ELECTED
SO IN THE 2018 CAMPAIGN HE
PLEDGED TO CLOSE CHARTERS DOWN
AND THEN THEY GAVE DISTRICTS
MORE POWER TO BLOCK THEM AND
IN EXCHANGE MILLIONS MORE
DOLLARS FROM THE UNIONS OF
COURSE THIS DOESN'T AFFECT HIM
HE SENDS HIS KIDS TO PRIVATE
SCHOOL LIKE OTHER LEADING
DEMOCRATS YOU KNOW HOW BAD THE
PUBLIC SCHOOL SYSTEM IS HOW
DISGUSTING THESE DEMOCRATS
TONIGHT.
THE EXACT SAME CHOICE THEY
DENY EVERYONE ELSE'S PARENTS
HOW SICKENING THEY ATTACKED
THE VERY SCHOOL THAT THEY HELP
TO SPEAK FOR THE MOST PROMPTED
BY PARENT FRUSTRATION OF
PANDEMIC CLOSURES IN THE LAST
FEW MONTHS WE HAVE SEEN
POSITIVE MOVES IN IOWA ARIZONA
AND ARKANSAS INDIANA KENTUCKY
MISSOURI ALL CREATED EDUCATION
SAVINGS ACCOUNTS TO BE PRIVATE
SCHOOL TUITION GIVING PARENTS
MORE CHOICE BUT HERE'S THE
TRUTH.
IT'S NOT ENOUGH.
EVEN IF THIS WAS ENACTED ONLY
A SMALL FRACTION OF AMERICA'S
CHILDREN WITH ACCESS TO THESE
OPPORTUNITIES A VAST MAJORITY
WOULD BE STUCK IN THE PUBLIC
SCHOOL SYSTEM AT THE MERCY OF
THE TEACHER UNION AND THE
EDUCATION BUREAUCRACY.
IT WILL ONLY GET WORSE THE
UNIONS POWER IS GROWING, NOT
SHRINKING THEY NOW HAVE A
MEMBER IN THE WHITE HOUSE THAT
BIDEN AND DISGRACEFUL HE
BOASTED EACH YEAR MORE
TEACHERS FOR OUT OF COLLEGES
AND TRAINING INSTITUTIONS
INFECTED WITH WOKE IS HIM - -
WOKENESS VERY DOING FIDDLING
AROUND WITH PIECEMEAL REFORM?
THE ENTIRE SYSTEM IS RAW AND
AND IS DRAGGING AMERICA DOWN
ECONOMICALLY AS A BETTER
EDUCATED WE ARE BEING LEFT IN
THE DUST AS THE ANTI- AMERICA
BRAINWASHING TAKES A DEEPER
HOLD.
THE BIGGEST THREAT WE FACE AND
WE ARE RUNNING AWAY FROM IT
INSTEAD OF CONFRONTING IT.
ENOUGH.
WE KNOW WHAT WORKS AND WE CAN
SEE WHAT DOESN'T.
IT'S TIME FOR REAL CHOICE IN
EDUCATION.
REAL POWER AND PARENTS HANDS.
REAL REFORM NOT IN NAME ONLY.
IT IS TIME TO AND THE PUBLIC
SCHOOL MONOPOLY.
ALL THE MONEY, THE ENTIRE
SCHOOLS BUDGET SHOULD BE
RETURNED TO PARENTS ON AN
EQUAL BASIS TO SPEND ON THE
EDUCATION THEY THINK IS BEST
FOR THEIR CHILD SOME KIDS WILL
THRIVE IN LARGER SCHOOLS
THANKS TO THE PANDEMIC THERE
HAS BEEN AN EXPLOSION OF
INNOVATION ENTREPRENEURIAL
ENERGY MICRO SCHOOLS AND
PARENT RUN SCHOOLS A HOST OF
OPTIONS IMAGINE HOW MUCH MORE
EDUCATION INNOVATORS KNEW THEY
HAD EVERY PARENT IN AMERICA AS
A POTENTIAL CUSTOMER AND IF WE
DO THIS IN FUND STUDENTS WE
CAN FINALLY SHUT DOWN THE
DISASTROUS ESTABLISHMENT AND A
LOCAL SCHOOL BUREAUCRACIES
THIS IS NOT A PIPE DREAM WITH
ANY LUCK AND WITH THE SUPPORT
OF THE SHOW WE COULD EVEN BE
ON THE BALLOT NEXT YEAR THANKS
TO CALIFORNIA SCHOOL CHOICE
FOUNDATION.
LET'S MAKE THIS A LITMUS TEST
FOR EVERY REPUBLICAN RUNNING
FOR OFFICE CLOSE DOWN THE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ABOLISH IT
ALL NO MORE MEDIOCRITY NO MORE
CRITICAL RACE THEORY NO MORE
NONSENSE FROM THE TEACHER
UNIONS EDUCATIONAL
ESTABLISHMENT AND THE OVERPAID
UNDERPERFORMING BUREAUCRATS
POWER TO PARENTS OPPORTUNITY